สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีนะคะ
กลับมาพบกับครูฟ้าแล้วก็ครูเรียมใน
beginner เนาะ beginner  4 นะคะ beginner
B4 วันนี้เจอกันนี่วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
พุธค่ะวันพุธวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
7 อื 7 อื 7 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กันยายน
กันยาปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
65 โอเคแล้วปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะอืตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะครูปาค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลา 1400
น 25 นค่ะ 25 นาทีอืเคเขียนแบบนี้มย 2.25
น 14 หรือป่าเออเป็น 14 เนาะถ้าเกิดแบบจะ
ต่อด้วยนอนหนูต้องเป็น 14
ใช่ 14 นแบบภาษาไทยนะคะแบบไทยอืภาษาบ่า
ใช่ 14:00 นหรือว่า 14  25 นนั่นแหละใช่
ค่ะถึงเวลานอนค่ะูฟังถึงเวลานอนแล้วใช่
มั้ย
คะต้องฟังนิทานต้องฟังนิทานหรือเปล่าใช่
ค่ะนักเรียนพอนักเรียนเปิด beginner สี
ขึ้นมาเนี่ยนักเรียนก็รู้เลยว่าได้เวลา
นอนนะคะนักเรียนก็จะเปิดฟังครูฟ้ากับครู
เรียมแล้วก็นอนเ่านักเรียนบอกว่าก็ไม่เคย
นอนนะไม่มีใครนอนนะนแต่ครูเนี่ยจะรู้สึก
ว่าง่วงูใช่ครูหาวนะ
เนี่ยแต่ครูฟ้าหาวเพราะว่าอะไรไม่รู้นะคะ
ว่าหาวบ่อยเป็นคนหาวบ่อยหาวบ่อยๆแต่ไม่
ได้ง่วงแต่หาวเคยได้ยินว่าออกซิเจนน้อย
มั้งออกซิเจนน้อยมันทำให้เราหาวได้อืนั่น
แหละแต่ว่าวันนี้เนี่ยแล้ววันนี้ครูฟ้ามี
เรื่องผีอะไรมาเล่าให้ฟังมวันนี้เรื่องผี
ไม่มีค่ะวันนี้ไม่ใช่เรื่องผีค่ะครูเรียม
ไม่
ใช่วันนี้เนี่ยมีเจ้าชเป็นเรื่องอุ้ยเจ้า
ชายหรอไม่เอาแล้วค่ะครูฟ้าเบื่อเจ้าชาย
มากค่ะครูเลียมวันนี้จะไม่เล่าเจ้าชาย
อืเหรอมีมั้ยน่ะไม่มีไม่มีไม่มีมีฟ้าเพ
ว่ามี 2 เรื่องนะคะอีกเรื่องมีเจ้าชาย
ด้วยแต่เรื่องนี้ไม่มีอ๋อเรื่องนี้ไม่มี
เจ้าชายค่ะไม่มีเจ้าชายเ่อเป็นเรื่องที่
เกิดใน
อิตาลีูฟ้ากำลังจะบอกว่าเป็นเรื่อง
จริงว่าไม่รู้นะคะแต่ว่ามีคนบอกว่าเป็น
นิทานได้ยินว่าเป็นนิทานเหมือนกันไม่รู้
ว่าเป็นเรื่องจริงมยว่าอาจจะเป็นนิทานก็
ได้หรือว่าเป็นเรื่องจริงก็ได้ไม่รู้เลย
นะคะไม่รู้เลยแต่ว่าเรื่องนี้เนี่ยเกิด
ขึ้นที่อิตาลีนานมาแล้วค่ะครูเรียมนานมา
แล้วเกิดอะไรขึ้นคะคูณ
ฟ้าก็มีผู้ชายคนนึงนะคะมีผู้ชายคนนึงอายุ
น่าจะ
40  50 ประมาณเนี้ยอือายุประมาณ 50 แล้ว
กัน 50 อายุ 50 ปีนะคะผู้ชายคนนี้เนี่ยมี
ลูกสาว 1 คน
อืมลูกสาวก็โตแล้วสวยมั้ยสวยค่ะครูเรียม
คิดว่าน่าจะ
อายุประมาณ 19  20 ประมาณนี้อ่า 19 ปี 20
ปีลูกสาวก็ยังเด็กอยู่นะคะยังเด็กอยู่
แล้ว
ก็สวยด้วยนะคะก็คุณพ่อกับลูกสาวเนี่ยเขาค
ก็ทำเหมือนเปิดร้านขายของใช่มยเปิดร้าน
ขายของคล้ายๆเว่นอวน่ะอืมเอว7วอวเนี่ยขาย
ของเนาะขายอาหารขายน้ำขายนมขาย
เอิ่มดินสอขายอะไรหลายๆอย่างใช่ไหมอืใช่
อืพ่อคนนี้ก็เปิดร้านขายของคล้ายๆเซเว่น
ใช่ค่ะครูเรียมคล้ายๆกันก็เปิดร้านแต่ 1
วันเนี่ยขายของได้น้อยมากอืขายของไม่ได้
เลยนะคะไม่มีคนไม่มีคนคนคมาซื้อ
ของก็ธุรกิจก็ไม่ดีใช่มไม่ดีไม่ดีไม่ดีจน
เงินหมด
อ้าวเงินหมดแล้วทำยังไงดีคะก็เปลี่ยนไปทำ
งานอย่างอื่นใช่มั้ยอาจจะต้องเปลี่ยนหรือ
เปล่าไม่รู้นะคะแต่ว่าคุณพ่อเนี่ยก็คิด
เงินหมดทำยัง
ไงเปลี่ยนงานไม่เอาไม่เอาไม่เอาไม่
เปลี่ยนงานไม่เปลี่ยนงานขายของดีแล้วแต่
ว่าไปยืมเงินละกันเอ้าหรอเรียมนึกว่าจะทำ
แบบ
โปรโมชั่นลดราคาสินค้า
50% ไม่ค่ะไปยืมเงินดีกว่ายืมเงินค่ะอื
ออยืมเงินที่ไหนดีคุณพ่อก็เสิร์ช
อินเทอร์เน็ตใช่มั้ยเอ๊เมื่อก่อนมี
อินเทอร์เน็ตหรือเปล่าไม่รู้นะเมื่อก่อน
ไม่มีอินเทอร์เน็ตอาจจะมีเป็นโปสเตอร์เออ
โปสเตอร์เป็นกระดาษแปะอยู่แล้วก็เอกระดาษ
ใช่มยคุณพ่อเก็ไปเจอกระดาษหรือว่าเขาอาจ
จะเจอคนที่แบบแต่งตัวสวยๆถ้าเกิดสมัยก่อน
นะูฟ้าอืๆใช่แต่งตัวดูแพงนะแพงมากแบบต้อง
ใส่ต้องใส่แหวนอ้าไม่มีแหวน
ใส่ไม่มีแหวนไม่มีแหวนแหวนไปไหน
หายเลยใส่แหวนใส่กำไลใส่สร้อยก็จะคิดว่า
รวยมากรวยจะไปยืมเงินเนี่ยต้องไปยืมเงิน
คนที่รวยใช่ไหมอ่าคุณพ่อเนี่ยก็ไปหามีใคร
ให้ยืมเงินได้บ้างก็ไปเจอผู้ชายคนนึงครู
ฟ้าจะเรียกผู้ชายคนนี้ว่าชายชราอือือชาย
ชราชราก็คือแก่ค่ะนักเรียนใช่แก่เนี่ยู
คิดถึงอายุ
ประมาณ 70 ม 60  70 เมคิดว่าประมาณ 80 นะ
เออหรือว่า 80  80 ปีก็แก่ 80  90
ออือายุเนาะอายุ 80 อือายุ 90  70  80  90
เนี่ยเราเรียกว่าชายชราอืคุณพ่อเนี่ยก็
เอ๊ะชายชราเนี่ยให้ยืมเงินอืมให้คนยืม
เงินใครไม่มีเงินไม่มีเงินบาทไม่มีเงิน
ดอลลาร์ไม่มีเงินเย็นเงินวอนไม่มีเงิน
อะไรคะ
รูปีอันนี้หลายประเทศเลยนะชายชราคนนี้ก็
ให้ยืมเงินอืใช่ค่ะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เรียมก็
ไม่มีเงินน่ะไม่มีเงินอ้าครูเรียใน
กระเป๋าใช่มั้ยคะไม่มีเงินเลยค่ะเรียมแบบ
นี้เรียมครูฟ้าได้มมั้ยได้ค่ะยิมเงินครู
ฟ้าได้ค่ะครูม 20 บาท 20 บาทเองเหรอคะทำ
อะไรคะไปซื้อซื้อน้ำมาดื่มอยู่น้ำใช่มั้ย
อ่าอันเนี้ยยืมเงิน
อืมคุณพ่อเนี่ยก็เลยคิดไปยืมเงินชายชรา
เออไปยืมเงินชายชราไม่รู้ว่ายืมมาเท่า
ไหร่นะคะอิตาลีนี่เงินอะไรเราก็ไม่รู้ว่า
เงินอะไรเนาะเป็นเงินอิตาลีนะคะก็ไปยืม
เงินมาเยอะมากอืมแล้วก็เอาไปใช้เอาไปดูแล
ร้านขายของอือื
แต่ยืมเงินมาแล้วก็ยังขายของไม่ดีเหมือน
เดิมค่ะครูเรี่มอ๋อหายของไม่ดีเลยแบบนี้
แล้วเวลาที่เรายืมเงินเราก็ต้องเอาเงินไป
คืนใช่เพราะว่าเรายืมเราไม่ได้ขอถ้าเกิด
ขอเงินแล้วอ่ะชายชราให้อันนี้ก็คือให้
เงินเลยนะคะไม่ต้องคืนแต่ถ้ายืมเงินอืม
อาจจะอ่ะยืมเงิน 100,000 บาทใช่ไหมมชาย
ชราก็ให้ยืมเงิน 100,000 บาทแล้วก็ให้
เวลา 100,000 บาทเนี่ยต้องเอามาคืน 1
เดือนอืครบ 1 เดือนแล้วต้องเอาเงินมาคืน
100,000 บาทใช่อาจจะบวกเพิ่มด้วยนะไม่
รู้เนาะนั่นแหละนะฮะคุณพ่อเนี่ยก็ยืมเงิน
มาเยอะมากแล้วก็เอามาทำขายของแต่ขายของก็
ยังไม่ดีเงินก็บ๊ายบายเงินก็เริ่มหมด
เริ่มหมดพอครบ 1 เดือนชายชราก็มาถามว่า
เงินของชชันอยู่ไหนเอาเงินมา
คืนเอาเงินมาคืนได้แล้วอ้าแต่พ่อขายของ
ไม่ดีนะขายของไม่ดีเลยจะเอาเงินเงินไปคืน
ชายชราได้หรอนั่นน่ะสิคะครูเรียมคุณพ่อ
เนี่ยก็เลยบอกว่าไม่มีเงินไม่มีเงินที่จะ
เอาไปคืนชาย
ชราชายชราก็เลย
อืถ้าไม่มีเงิน
ฉันได้ยินว่าอืมีลูกสาวใช่
มยใช่คุณมีลูกสาวใช่มยถ้าอย่างงั้นก็ให้
ลูกสาวมาแต่งงานกับฉันจะได้ไม่ต้องเอา
เงิน
คืนนักเรียนลูกสาวอายุเท่าไหร่นะลูกสาว
อายุประมาณ 20 เองอืชายชราอายุ 70  80
ทำไมเนี่ยทำไมทำไมอยากแต่งงานกับเด็กน้อย
อืมเพราะว่าลูกสาวสวยหรือเปล่าออไม่รู้นะ
ไม่ได้ลูกสาวอาจจะสวยนะคะชชคุณพ่อแบบโอเค
มั้ยคะคุณพ่อก็ไม่อยากให้ลูกสาวแต่งงาน
กับชายชรานะคะคุณพ่อบอกไม่เอาไม่เอาแต่
ลูกสาวเนี่ยก็ลูกสาวคิดว่าลูกสาวจะแต่ง
งานจะได้ช่วยให้คุณพ่อเนี่ยไม่ต้องหาเงิน
เอาไปคืนใช่มยอืมเพราะว่าถ้าแต่งงานก็ไม่
ต้องเอาเงินไป
คืนแต่ชายชราเนี่ยก็ยัง
โอเคคิดเกมขึ้นมาดีกว่าให้แต่งงานเลย
เนี่ยไม่สนุกคิดเกมละกันอืจะได้ชายชราจะ
ได้ดูเป็นคนใจดีอ๋อชายชราก็เลยคิดเกมขึ้น
มาให้ลูกสาวนะคะก็เข้าไปคุยกับลูกสาวเนาะ
แล้วชายชราก็บอก
ว่าเธอเธอฉันมีช้อยส์มีเกมมาให้เธอเล่น
เป็นช้อยส์
ฉันเนี่ยจะมีถุงผ้า 2 ถุงอืมออถุงผ้าแบบ
นี้ถุงผ้าค่ะครูเรียมใช่ถุงผ้าแบบนี้
เนี่ยคือถุงผ้าอืแต่ครูฟ้าบอกว่ามี 2 ถุง
มี 2 ถุงครูเรียมมี 2 ถุงเหรอคะโหครู
เรียมก็มีถุงมี 2
ถุงมีถุงผ้า 2  2 ถุง 2 แล้วทำมถุง 2 ถุง
แล้วทำยังไงแล้วชายชราเนี่ยก็ไปหยิบก้อน
กรวด
มาในถุงผ้าเนี่ยจะมีก้อนก้อนกรวด 2 ก้อน
อือืก้อนกรวดค่ะก้อนกรวดแบบนี้ใช่ค่ะก้อน
กรวดอืก็คือหินก้อนเล็กๆใช่ค่ะก้อนหินก็
ได้หรือว่าก้อนกรวดก็ได้ถ้าเป็นหินมันอาจ
จะใหญ่ใช่มยแต่ถ้าก้อนกรวดเนี่ยมันจะเล็ก
นะคะเล็กอือันนี้เนี่ยเป็นก้อนกรวดใช่ก็
คือชายชราเนี่ยบอกว่าจะเอาก้อนกรวดเนี่ย
ใส่ในถุงผ้าใส่ลงไปถุงผ้าถุงที่ 1 ก็จะมี
ก้อนกรวด 1 ก้อนถุงผ้าถุงที่ 2 ก็จะมี
ก้อนกรวดอีก 1 ก้อนใช่ชลาเล่นเกมอะไร
เนี่ยใช่เกมอะไรเนี่ยแต่ว่าก้อนกรวด 2  2
ก้อนเนี่ยจะมีสีไม่เหมือนกันนะคะครูเรียม
ออมีสีอะไรบ้างคะจะมีสีขาวกับสีดำอือ๋อจะ
มีสีขาวแล้วก็มีสีดำแบบนี้ใช่ค่ะครูเรียม
สีดำอืก้อนกรวดสีดำขาวดำขาวดำใช่ไหมแล้ว
จะทำอะไรคะจะให้ทำอะไรคะก้อนกวดสีขาว
สีดำชายชราบอกกับหญิงนะคะผู้หญิงคนนี้ว่า
ชั้นเนี่ยจะมีถุงผ้า 2 ถุงแลข้างในก็จะมี
ก้อน
กรวดให้ผู้หญิงเนี่ยเลือกจะเอาถุงที่ 1
หรือว่าถุงที่
2 ถ้าผู้หญิงเลือกถุงที่มีก้อนกรวดสีดำ
อืหมาย
ถึงผู้หญิงเนี่ยจะต้องแต่งงานกับชายชรา
อ๋อแล้วถ้าเลือกได้อีกถุงนึงล่ะคะถ้า
เลือกได้อีกถุงนึงที่เป็นก้อนกรวดสีขาวก็
ไม่ต้องแต่งงานเก็ดีโอเคนะเร็มว่าแบบได้
เลือกใช่ๆอย่างน้อยก็ได้เลือกนะและคุณพ่อ
ก็ไม่ต้องเอาเงินมาคืนด้วยนะถ้าได้ก้อน
กรวดสีขาวเนี่ยออใชลาใจดีจังเงินเออใจดี
ใช่ไหมมชายชราก็เลยพาหญิงเนี่ยเดินเข้ามา
ในที่ที่มีก้อนกรวดนะคะเป็นก้อนกรวดเยอะๆ
เลยแล้วชายชลก็เลยหยิบก้อนกรวดขึ้นมา
เนี่ยแบบเนี้ยหยิบขึ้นมาแต่เด็กผู้หญิง
เนี่ยเห็นว่าชายชราซิกแซกค่ะครูเรียมซิก
แซกซิกแซกยังไงคะชายชราหยิบก้อนกรวดสีดำ
ทั้ง 2 ก้อนเลยอ้าวไหนบอกว่าว่า 1 ถุงสี
ดำอีก 1 ถุงก็สีขาวไม่ค่ะชายชราหยิบก้อน
กรวดขึ้นมาสีดำทั้งหมดแล้วก็เอาใส่ลงไปใน
ถุงที่ 1 เสร็จแล้วก็เอาถุงที่ 2 ก็ใส่
ก้อนกรวดสีดำลงไป
อีกมีก้อนกวดสีดำ 2 ถุงสีดำ 2 ก้อนใช่ 2
ถุงเลยเด็กผู้หญิงก็เห็นว่าชายชราเนี่ย
ซิกแซกเด็กผู้หญิงก็คิดทำยังไงดี
ล่ะถ้าจะจะเลือกถุงที่ 1 ก็ต้องแต่งงาน
หรือจะเลือกถุงผ้าถุงที่ 2 ก็ต้องแต่ง
งานทำยังไงดีทำยังไงดีชายชราก็บอกอ่ะ
เลือกมาจะเอาถุงที่ 1 หรือถุงที่
2 นิสัยไม่ดีนะคะชายชราเนี่ยไม่ดีซิกแซก
มากๆผู้หญิงเด็กผู้หญิงคนนั้นก็เลยทำยไง
คะเลือกถุง
ไหนอัถุงที่ 1 แล้วกันเด็กผู้หญิงก็เรียก
ถุงที่ 1 ชายชราก็เอาถุงที่ 1 เนี่ยให้
เด็กผู้หญิงนะคะเด็กผู้หญิงก็หยิบถุงผ้า
มาแล้วก็เปิดถุงผ้าออแล้วก็เอามือเข้าไป
ในถุง
ผ้าเด็กผู้หญิงก็คิดแบบนี้ดีกว่าอืผู้
หญิงก็เลยหยิบก้อนกรวดออกมาแล้วก็ทำก้อน
กรวดอันเนี้ยหล่นลงไปที่พื้นอืมอืซึ่งที่
พื้นเนี่ยจะมีก้อนกรวดเยอะมากเลยแบบที่
ครูเรียมให้ดูเห็นมั้ยใช่แล้วก็อ้าก้อน
ไหนผู้หญิงก็เลยทำเป็นหยิบก้อนกรวดแล้วก็
ทำหล่น
เอ้าก้อนกรวดหล่นลงไปที่พื้นแล้วอืตอนนี้
ไม่รู้แล้วว่าก้อนกรวดสีอะไรเพราะว่าที่
พื้นเนี่ยมีก้อนกรวดสีขาวสีดำสีขาวสีดำ
เต็มไปหมด
อืมแล้วทีนี้ทำยังไงคะก็จะรู้ได้ยังไงอ่ะ
ผู้หญิงก็บอกชายชราว่า
เอ้าขอโทษค่ะฉันทำก้อนกรวดหล่นลงไปที่
พื้นตอนนี้ไม่รู้แล้วว่าหยิบก้อนกรวดสี
อะไร
อ้าวผู้หญิงก็เลยบอกว่าชชายชราก็เอ้าทำไม
ทำหล่น
ผู้หญิงก็เลยบอกว่าไม่เป็นไรไม่เป็นไรถ้า
อย่างนั้นก็ให้ชายชราเปิดถุงผ้าถุงที่ 2
ดูว่าถุงผ้าถุงที่ 2 เป็นสีอะไรใช่มย
เพราะว่าผู้หญิงเนี่ยเลือกมาแล้วถุงนึง
แล้วก็ทำหล่นไปแต่ก็ไม่เป็นไรก็ไปเช็คดู
ในถุงที่ 2 ไงถ้าถุงที่ 2 เป็นสีขาวก็
หมายถึงผู้หญิงเลือกสีดำมาแต่ถ้าถุงที่ 2
มีก้อนกรวดสีดำก็หมายถึงผู้หญิงเลือกก้อน
กรวดสีขาว
มาอืมอแต่จำได้ว่าในถุงก็มีก้อนกรวดสีดำ
ทั้ง 2 ถุงทั้ง 2 ถุงเลยชายชราก็เลยคิดทำ
ยังไง
ดีถ้าเปิดออกมาก็เป็นสีดำหมาย
ถึงผู้หญิงก็เลือกเค้าก็จะเข้าใจว่าเค้า
เลือกสีขาวมามาก็ไม่ต้องแต่งงานใช่มยใช่
แต่ชายชราจะพูดออกไปว่าตัวเองซิกแซกก็ไม่
ได้อืทำให้ชายชราก็ต้องยอมเปิดถุงผ้าแล้ว
ก็หยิบก้อนกรวดออกมาให้ดูนะคะออกมาโชว์
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงคนนั้นก็เลยอ่าอันนี้เนี่ย
ก้อนกรวดสีดำแปลว่าฉันเลือกก้อนกรวดสีขาว
มาฉันก็ไม่ต้องแต่งงานและคุณพ่อก็ไม่ต้อง
คืนเงินให้กับชายชราด้วยแฮปปี้มากเห็นมย
นะคะโสุดยอดเลยอ่ะแล้วถ้าเกิดชายชราเอา
ออกมาแล้วแบบทำก้อนหินร่วงปเ้าก้อนไหน
หยิบใหม่ไม่รู้ไม่รู้ไม่รู้นะคะแต่ว่าผู้
หญิงฉลาดมากอืมเห็นมั้ยผู้หญิงฉลาดมาก
เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยเราก็ต้องคิดเยอะๆนะคะ
นักเรียนเวลาเจอกับอะไรที่
มันแย่แล้วทำยังไงดีทำยังไงดีเราต้องคิด
อืคิดคิดมากๆว่าจะมีทางไหนที่สามารถทำได้
อีกใช่มอืมใช่พอผู้หญิงคนนี้คิดได้แล้วเา
ก็ไม่ต้องจ่ายเงินใช่มั้คะต้องจ่ายเงิน
ไม่ต้องแต่งงานไม่ต้องแต่งงานนะคะอันนี้
ก็เป็นนิทานที่ครูว่าเอามาเล่าให้ครู
เรียมกับนักเรียนฟังเห็นมยสุดยนอนๆละเล่า
ไปก็นอนหลับได้แล้วนะคะแต่ว่าเพราะฉะนั้น
เนี่ยตอนนี้หมดเวลาแล้วให้ครูเรียมไปหลับ
ดีกว่านะคะครูฟ้าก็ง่วงแล้วนะคะนักเรียน
เพราะฉะนั้นเราลานักเรียนก่อนนะคะอ่ะลา
นักเรียนก่อนค่ะโอเคเจอกันคลิปวดีโอหน้า
ค่ะครูฟ้าได้ค่ะก็สวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบายสวัสดี
ค่ะบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะ